The platform through its.
I mean, every other people have
access to it, but I'll probably
be the one doing the heavy duty
testing. Perfect. So we have to
hear what you sorry.
Would be great to hear what you
what you think Judis.
Um, perfect. Cool. So yeah, just
to point out, myself and Magda,
we're not. We're not developers.
Um, we've not built the platform
ourselves. So yeah, a couple of
things. I would encourage you to
be very open and honest. You're
not gonna offend myself or
Magda. The only thing we're
doing is we're obtaining your
feedback and we're just passing
it to the right people. So say
what you want, and the second
thing is speak out loud. Don't
you know you don't need to wait
for us to pause for you to give
feedback. If you want to say
something, if you think
something, just say out loud.
That's the kind of feedback that
we want.
That's fine. I don't wanna talk
over people. It's, I tell it too
easy to do it. So I may just
raise my hand. No problem. No
problem. That's cool. That's
cool, cool. So maybe if we start
by if you could explain maybe a
little bit about your role and
how you use evaluate and then
Magda wants, once I've done
that, you want to maybe share
your screen and show the
platform. Yeah, sounds good.
Cool.
You're just, you wanna go, OK.
You know we are a contract
development manufacturing
organization. So we may tend to
use the platform a little
differently than the the big,
big and little bio pharmas. But
we utilize a lot of different
segments, modules of the
platform. We're looking for
sales for market size. We we
look at the Omnium data, Omnium
risk data for input into some of
our forecasting.
Models, we are now just started
using the return data and we're
we're developing use cases for
that across our group. We have
done a little bit with it for
business development finding
business develop and we'll
probably be able to use some of
the peak sales data as a
triangulation and and where
there's a gap for private
companies because there's
there's no not a lot of there's
only reported sales so.
Where we don't have any
forecasts, we could possibly
look at using some of the peak
sales in Omnium return. So we
work very closely with
marketing, business development,
IE sales and strategy. We're
Cornell and I are part of the
strategy department.
In addition, I would say one of
the main.
So we use this to look at
aggregate markets. You know we
use this to look at individual
products as well. You know we
produce now just under 8000
products for our customers in
the market, in the market. So
understanding what's happening
to our customers products is
useful to us. They give us
forecasts but they're not always
you know there are different
forecasts and companies and we
always get the procurement ones
which are tend to be making sure
they have enough.
Rather than the you know IR ones
that are making sure they don't
get caught by by surprises so so
so we use you know the data for
triangulation for you know
customer forecast for products
as well and then some of the.
Umm.
You know there, there are, there
are ways we have used some of
the other data sets you know the
the Clinton Trials Registry data
sets the, you know FDA.
You know the FDA drugs that FDA
type datasets um as well over
over time. So there are very few
pieces.
There are pieces, but there are
very relatively very few pieces
to which we have access that we
haven't used. We did have access
to API's and you know, we're
less. We found we found issues
with the data set at the time,
so we moved away from that, but
that's the only.
Issue we've we've had so.
And we have used it for various
initiatives for targeting and
things like that. For pipeline,
we tend to focus on pharma
projects which will now be more
in your bailiwick. One piece of
advice, I just keep telling
everyone that we want to see a
simple user interface such as
farmer projects has. Now I don't
know how the plans are, how to
integrate it, but it needs to
have a simple.
Um, user-friendly interface that
the drug mapping is excellent in
pharma projects. You don't need
to know what name you're going
with, you just need to have a
name that's very useful for
people who are not heavy duty
users. I heard the plans to
changing some of the taxonomy,
getting rid of some of the
biotech from the therapeutic
class and putting it in the
origin.
So those things we will be
watching closely moving forward.
Yeah. And you know I I don't
think that the purpose of this
call was to talk about the
integration of the information,
but I just, I just keep saying
that but but I'll echo that to
Farmer project plays a even more
important role for us than
evaluate does and we have broad
broad access in the company for
that. Don't screw it up is my
ask to review management and you
know the quality of.
That is so much better than the
pipeline data and evaluate right
now at an at an aggregate
company level not the
individual. Well, even at an
individual level you know you if
you look at your pipeline
project counts, you know you're
duplicating projects across
different companies and things
like that. So the farmer
projects is gold standard data.
So please if you're going to use
it move that direction and don't
move them your direction because
it'll.
It'll it'll be a problem for us,
but that's a different,
different point. This is
actually really useful honest
feedback which we really
appreciate. We are doing some
work in the early stage pipeline
space, so hopefully you will be
able to see some of the changes.
And then in terms of API kernel,
you mentioned there were some
issues, so you no longer have
the subscription. We have also
made some changes recently and
we have mapped the epidemiology.
Data to evaluate indications and
detailed indications. So maybe I
could get you in touch with
someone who could walk you
through it and you could see if
maybe that kind of data analysis
is available is.
Something useful for for
yourself. OK. You know we can
Judith we we've had.
Judith, I don't remember the the
contacts at the time, but you
know, we did a kind of a special
data poll and you know,
communicated back the issues
that we found.
Mapping issues to the correct
level, it was also they were
pulling it from the back end. So
I I think that what you're just
saying about improving the
mapping of the indications could
be a valuable improvement that
we would want to say yes, OK,
perfect. I'll get someone to.
To get in touch with you then.
OK, cool. So we jump on to the
the new platform now.
Awesome. Let me just share my
screen quickly and just to just
to be clear, just if you did
mention.
You know in terms of data that
you you will be watching very
closely how the data changes.
When it comes to the new
platform, the data stays the
same. So whatever changes we are
going to do in terms of taxonomy
that's that's separate project.
So whatever the data we have at
evaluate that's going to be
migrated strictly straight to
the new platform, so.
Don't worry, there you will
still be able to see the same
data. So at the moment the new
platform can be accessed through
the beta button that you have
available and then as you click
through that link it takes you
to.
To our new home page.
So we are at this stage of
testing, so you get a little pop
up here, but yeah so this is the
let me just make it smaller so
you can see the whole thing. So
this is the.
The landing page.
Some of those things are
placeholders to give you an idea
what it will look like when it's
fully built. So at the moment
some of those things are just to
give you a little bit of a
preview what we are thinking
about like news Market Explorer
and then quick links and things
like that. At the moment we are
able to.
Sorry.
Sorry I thought someone said
something. Um, so at the moment
we are able to access the data
via 2 routes. So we can either
create a report from scratch by
clicking through here or we can
go through the menu button and
go to specific pages. So.
Before I jump onto the creating
a report, just wanted to point
out that when you save your
reports they will be available
here in the order of which one
you have saved or edited.
Recently, most recently so. So
this is going to give you a
quick.
Quick access to to your reports
as well. So um yeah, before I
click on the create a new report
button, is there anything that
you would like to give us
feedback on when it comes to the
landing page here I would.
You know the.
The ease of being able to click
through the current.
Data dimensions in the current
menu. You know the current
landing page menu structure and
find the sub report the sub
section that you need.
Is is easy and even in today's
like browse feature which is
this looks similar to the browse
feature, very difficult to find
some of those subsections in the
way that it's very easy to find
them in the other current
landing page. So we have this
issue, I'll say sorry, this
reminds me of an issue we have
with other datasets that are
designed for product managers.
That when you get to the landing
page you primarily care about
one therapeutic area or one
product or whatever and so you
have the heavy graph and things
like that. We don't use the data
set that way because we have to
we we basically make products in
nearly every therapeutic
category for customers you know
and and and for thousands of
companies and things like that.
So we don't have that luxury and
so spending all the the.
I'm focusing on a few things
instead and and making it more
difficult for us to get to
individual pieces because I
don't want to have to create a
report every time I need
something, you know, and we
can't, at least in the current
browse. So I didn't look at
this. In the current browse we
can't get to all of those
subsets very easily, easily and
very quickly. This would make my
my usage harder.
OK, personal opinion so.
Even having the option of, you
know, using either interface
would be nice. You know, there
might be times when this
interface would be better,
especially if we could say,
look, we're, you know, we could
build a custom, you know, custom
market and it's only the
products we make or something,
you know, whatever. You know,
maybe there would be times that
would be valuable, but I I'd
hate to lose the flexibility of
the old.
Drill down to.
Yeah, one thing that I think
he's alluding to, you can see
the structure of everything. You
can see all the different
modules and what's available and
maybe that's in the menu section
a little bit more. But even
though it's a little complex, I
think in looking at all those
modules, if you're familiar with
it, you know where it is you
want to go and you can get to it
very quickly.
Cornell said. We work across not
only all therapeutic areas but
all modalities. So we do
manufacture small molecule
biologics and cell and gene
therapies. So there isn't one
specific niche that we focus on.
OK, understood. So you mean that
in in terms of here for example
you would want to see um a quick
links to therapeutic category
and then you can drill through
specific ones or indications is
that is that what I'm hearing
that you would?
So can you click on the first
tab?
Click on the first step. There
you go. Just the old interface
tab. Oh, sorry. Oh, yeah, yeah,
yeah. So, you know, I, I most
often use drugs. Tab, a valued
Omnia, you know, and here I can
go to, you know, one click
because it normally lands here.
So one click, I can go to global
analysis, you know, you know, I
can go to.
You know some of the some of
these other cuts, so they're not
analogy. I often go in
technology, you know, I can go
Click to the tab, click one
thing and get to kind of the
common set of reports if you
try. If I try to do the same
with browse, I often you know
which I think is similar to
what's in the new. I can't even
figure out how to get to some of
these areas and browse.
Yeah, that that does make sense
and it's really useful to to
know this actually. So it will
definitely take that back to the
team and I and I would describe
there, there may be, it may be,
you know since I've been using
the the app so long or the NOT
app but the service so long. You
know, I tend to think of myself
as a power user and that it may
be a difference between an
average user and a power user
view or something. Yeah, I think
so.
But, but just so that's that's
kind of my should illustrate my
feedback, but, and I have the
same reaction as Cornell, the
browser is.
Doesn't really help me a lot. I
like the the analyze this this
interface. I know I can go to
drugs, omnium ordeals, which is
where I tend. Those are the
three places I tend to go and
it's everything is right.
I can see all the sections of
all the modules right there, so
I know what's in it.
Absolutely, that does make
sense. And I guess when you're
used to one way of finding
things, you can just do it with
a couple of clicks, um, with
your eyes closed. Let's, let's,
let's take an example. So say I
wanted to do a, a, A.
Uh global you know, global
analysis sales by technology
forecast report in the new
interface.
How would I, you know, can I
browse? Because right now I
don't think you can easily
browse that so.
So that's a good question
Colonel as and you know as I
mentioned a lot of things are
being built and feedback like
yours actually helps us. So you
know whatever you say it's going
to put us on the right track. So
it's really useful to know that
this is the way that you would
start your research with without
you know instead of going to a
specific thing you would want to
see the full global analysis and
then you're drilling down the
idea behind this platform is for
users to be able to get as
granular as they want.
To the data starting from the
very top. But then as you look
at this, these are all the
placeholders at the moment. So
we are building and it's useful
to know if you did mention that
you want to go quickly to deal
so you will be able to do it
here. But it's really useful to
know which level you would want
to start your analysis from as
well. So yes, thank you for that
feedback. So I think this comes
back to the different user, the
different user types.
Yeah, because you know again as
you were showing that the kind
of the competitor and whatnot,
that's very much a product
management centric profile and
we don't primarily use this
data. We do have some people
within our user group that may
use certain parts of the data
like they care about the oral
products we make or something.
But you know for for the way we
use it we tend we we're not
start you know we're starting
with this.
Like with this, not with this.
And so, so um, so having
something that starts.
What you say is broad, but to me
is more narrow. You know is, is
and again we're different. CDO's
would use this service different
than normal product management
types. We know that or or or
than. Wall Street types too. So
when you did click on the menu,
I did see some examples where
you could go straight to Omnium,
straight to EPI.
And straight to and and are
those clickable or are those
just dummy links right now,
placeholders at the moment, not
right now. We can go to drugs or
companies. Well, go to drugs and
let's see what.
What?
Because if so this is a high
level KPI so you can see the the
forecast, you can see how many
drugs we've got in our in our
database by phase and then a
placeholders at the moment. But
the recent events from event
analyzer offering and then top
three by MOA indication,
therapeutic category and then
the data table here that you can
edit.
As well.
Yeah. So, so The thing is like
where, where would global
analysis?
So that's the yeah.
So the the the top level here
that's that would be the.
The yeah that double analysis, I
don't need a dashboard that's
not what because I you know I
use evaluate probably almost
every day you know at least
every other day and I'm not
going in to say what's happened
to the pipeline yesterday versus
today that's you know or is is
worldwide sales up or down by
you know $10 million you know
forecast that's not that's not
the you know so this is using a
lot of.
Screen real estate that I would
just have to scroll past or
click through. Yeah you know
that and and I would I would
suspect you know unless this can
be customized to you know any
given user specific you know
category of interest that that
would probably be more frequent
than less frequent across users.
I agree, unless if there's a way
to uh.
Customize it for maybe a
project, projects that you're
working on or you're a constant
things that you're looking at.
Not mechanism, different
attributes.
Um, that possibly could be
useful, but yeah, uh, we're
using it usually to answer
specific questions. So we, you
know, a lot of times there's a
lot of data involved not
necessarily going, sometimes
we're going in to look at one
compound, but often it's, it's a
broader view.
Understood. That's really useful
feedback. Is there anything
specific that you would rather
see here instead of those? Then
what would you, what would be
your ideal case scenario? You
click through drugs and then
what would you would want to
see? Well, you know what, what I
thinking about some other apps,
applications that we use, you
know the way to look at either a
dashboard or like a research
view, you know, so maybe having
the option of saying, OK, I want
to look at the big picture once
in a while.
For whatever reason, you know
being able to go this way um,
but um, but like having having
dashboards be optional or opt in
or something instead of it being
mandatory, yeah, we would be
more interested in it in in
data, some sort of data
visualization, dashboard graphs
after we run a query.
And then seeing what the data is
showing us like you know farmer
projects right now is very very
very basic dashboards, some bar
graphs and and a few other
things. But you know building on
that kind of thing you run a
query you, you, you have the
data if there is, you know data
manipulation, visualization on
the query that you ran.
That would be useful.
And or taking you know reports
you develop, queries you ran,
you know, being able to adapt
that to a a user defined
dashboard. You know, so I I only
want to look at, you know, the
8000 kind of products, not that
they're all in evaluate, but I
only want to look at the 8000
products that Catalent produces.
So we, you know, run a report we
then link that to a dashboard
and that's my user defined
dashboard maybe. I know that's a
like different order of
magnitude.
Complexity for programming
purposes, I get that, but.
You know anyway I think we I
could see people in OPS who why
would we be tracking certain
things subset like Cornell
saying and maybe having a
dashboard for that. In fact I
was at one point you utilizing
evaluate data we were developed
I was working with one of our
office people for them to
develop their own dashboard with
the data. So they may actually
want something where they could
see that but that's that's a
tactical.
Operational thing versus a
strategy thing, so two
different.
Use cases.
Understood. Um, so OK, so in
that case, would you would you
like if we had a function here
that you can filter this data to
a specific segment that you are
interested in and then have it
saved so whenever you click
through the menu to go to the
drugs page, then you will see
whatever you filtered on last
time?
It would make it more, make this
view more useful, but it would
still not. It would still not
make it more useful than the
other type of usage approach
that I think if we want to go
into the pipeline data, we want
to start searching right away as
opposed to viewing any.
Umm.
You know, there, there could be
things up here that could be
useful, but right now, you know
part of it, it's our habit as
well, yeah.
Again, I think if there's some
sort of.
Customization as one could do on
these things, then maybe it
could be more useful.
That's very good feedback. Thank
you. Um, the idea behind this is
also that you will, you should
be able to, you will be able to
Click to click through these. So
for example if you click through
phase two, this will then
transform into data that relates
only to face two products that
we have in the evaluate
universe.
So the the kind of drilling that
I was talking about drilling
through the through the data
tomorrow to get more detail
analysis that's also that's also
how we want to, how we want to
build this. So you know maybe
would that be useful as well
maybe one thing you know the way
we use this.
Is, I'll say complex query
driven.
So we're not primarily using,
OK, I need to look at an
indication, I need to look at
the top ten competitor. You know
again we're not using it as
product managers. So, so most of
what we're doing here is.
Is um.
Finding a so phase two for
instance here click think
clicking through a phase. We
wouldn't just care about phase
two in general, but we're
looking at you know, phase two
that you know for a certain
technology subtype that you
know.
You know maybe for you know if
if it's relevant for certain
route of administration you know
and that's and that's our
starting point you know and and
then you know maybe adding.
You know activity based sector
like market CAP or something
else in which by the way we've
asked time and time again we'd
love that to be a reportable
event and not just a filterable
thing as those market cap
activities because we use that
as a way to look at company
company sectors. But so we would
develop a report like that and
that would be you know that's
the usage approach we normally
take is is complex query.
Urban, not unfiltered. Top down.
So we're looking at multiple
attributes and I I would say
that you know, if we were going
to have an additional filter on
the top which would make
everything smaller, it would be
something like origin or you
know, technology here. Yeah, the
technology, the, I'm sorry, the
technology, yeah. Is it selling
gene therapy, is it small, small
molecule?
So it would be more if we were
going to filter on anything
would more likely be that and
possibly route of
administration. Mm-hmm. And I
understood I as I said I need to
drop for another call. So Judith
carry that, carry the flag
forward. Thanks. Thank you very
much. Very useful feedback.
Bye, bye.
Um, so Judith, do you ever, if
you start your analysis and go
to a specific page, for example,
do you ever edit or create your
your reports? I know you
mentioned at the start that you
rarely create a report from
scratch, but would you? No. No,
I we create reports from scratch
all the time. But it depends
where we Cornell likes to go in
by global analysis. He's
extremely strategic oriented. I
tend to be doing a lot of odd ad
hoc work.
Or.
Helping with market landscaping
right. So I I may be doing
things on a slightly narrower
focus So what what are what are
the reported sales for selling
gene therapy and and and the
specific?
Aspects of selling gene therapy.
I've been using more and more
the the sub, the sub
technologies as well, and my
feelings on the sub technologies
are mixed.
They're not in a hierarchy, and
I kind of understand why,
because they'd be in too many
hierarchies probably.
Um, but it it there's a lot of
them. So I'm not sure what the
best way to deal with the sub
hierarchies are the the sub
technologies are, but it it's
it's good that you have that I I
have been using that more and
more as we're looking at the
cell and gene therapy in a
slightly more granular fashion.
It allows us to umm, I was able
to use the Omnium return data
for.
Allogeneic.
Um, therapies.
OK. Well we we do have a
internal specialist who has been
working on the on technology
subtypes. So we'll definitely
communicate your feedback to to
him and if there is any
discussion that needs to happen
if you would be up for it he he
will be more than happy to to
discuss it in detail as well.
Unfortunately we're we're both
with Ankit we're not really the
specialist in that area so I
wouldn't want to give you any
false.
Information in that subject.
If that's OK.
Could I just show you quickly
how we have changed the report
building of yes, yes, yes, yes,
that's important. OK. So as I
said, you have the embedded
report here and as you hover
over the column titles, you can
see that the three dot menu pops
up so you can.
You can manipulate this report
further with columns that are
already here. You can sort and
then you can filter on specific
things. You can also pin your
column to the left. So then now
we have the company column on
the left hand side and as we
scroll to the right to see the
rest of the data you can see
what it relates to.
Perfect. Yeah, that that drives
me. That's in platforms for
most. Most platforms don't do
that. And I I think that's very
important. We don't look at the
data a lot on the screen though.
Yes, we we, we look to see that
we're getting what we want and
then we're exporting it because
we're often dealing with large
datasets. So there are people
who might manipulate much here
and sometimes I might do that,
but in general, pardon me.
In general, I'm more likely to
make sure I have the columns in
the right order, scroll back and
forth to make sure everything's
the way I want it, and and then
export it. So I'm not going to.
I may do some filtering just to
see if the data is what I expect
it to be.
Yes, I may do some filtering or
sorting to see if the data is
what I expect. Yeah, yeah that's
that makes sense. There is an
option to export your report in
CSV or Excel file and then also
that little icon gives you the
ability to save your reports. So
then you can access it through
here or on that landing page
when I showed you. So we can
just pick up where you left off
last time. Let me just show you
how to manipulate your report
further so as you can you click
through the manage columns you
are able to.
Add to your report. This is the,
UM, the fault that we have on
the site on that page currently.
You are able to then drop down
your options here so you have
the classification fields that
you can drill into. You can
select all of them at once you
can search for.
Indications you can search for
the for the specific column if
you know the name, if not then
they are.
What are grouped by by specific
folders? Sorry, what's the?
What's the difference between
the search ohh search for the
columns at? And? What's the
search other search bar? What's
the difference between the two
search bars?
I don't believe there is one.
OK, that's confusing just on
that one. So sorry ma'am, if you
just press the little cross on
that search, but you're on, so
you could see different entities
there. You've got a drug company
and indication.
Um, yeah, just press that. Click
in.
Hmm, so if you use the top
search bar, it searches across
all three entities?
And then you've also got a
search bar within each entity.
So if you just want to search
within drugs, you can do that.
If you want to just search
across, then you can just use
the top search bar. Oh, OK, you
need to make that more clear.
Yes. Understood.
Ohh, so, umm, we have selected
indications, so that was, um,
indications summary. So that was
added at the bottom here as you
can see today. So now we have
that little hand that we can
just drag and drop and change
the order of columns as you wish
on the right side indication
summary.
Indication summary the IT just
says indications how where the.
Oh OK, indication summary OK,
because it's a specific folder
and in the brackets it tells you
how many specific fields you
have in that category, for
example.
OK, so right. And then we can
delete columns as well if you
don't, if we don't need them. So
let's move a little bit.
Um, some of them out. And then,
yeah, the drag and drop, you can
see where it's going to end up
and as we click apply changes,
all of that is going to.
Be applied here you can see.
Your data is in that right order
now.
We haven't added any sales data
here, so let me just.
Let me just add a couple um
dates.
I just want to quickly show you
the differences in terms of the
filtering ability for different
field types, so bear with.
Peak sales should do OK.
So so this integrates all the
the platform information in
here.
Yes. Well, not that, not yet,
but will because yeah, as I
said, you know some of the data
is not there yet, but yes, we
will be migrating everything.
OK. So we have added, uh, what
we have added, so we've added
the sales data, so you can see
now.
Ohh that's big sales. So that
would be at the filter. So these
filters, they work more or less
like like they would in Excel.
So you can you can.
Excuse me, you can filter on
specific ranges between less
equal to um and then you can you
can select your ranges here you
can sort with descending or
ascending as well. So so these
are the options that we have
added to make it more editable
before you export to XLS well.
And I don't think we've got a.
A date field? But what do you
think, Judith? Is that
something? It looks good. It
looks a little more, uh, a
little easier to use as opposed
to having to press the arrow and
sending it back.
Right. Which is, you know, a
little early 2000s called. It
wants its interface back. Um.
I I think, you know, I'd have to
play with it more. But I think
it, I think it works. Uh, drugs
company. It may be a little
clearer than all the different
segments now, but I have to, I'd
have to, I'll I'll take some
time to go through it and look.
Pardon me.
Hey, hold up before the alarm
today. That's never good.
Wow, how did that happen? I am
not sure.
Never happens to me. It does not
usually happen. And then I'm
sitting there going, well, is
it? My husband covers the clock
and I had turned my phone off.
I'm like, OK, it's 5:50, is it
5:00 o'clock in the morning.
What time is it? Do I get up? Do
I know?
Ohh, so it would be good to go
through these and and I'll.
Look at everything and and see
if I and one thing, one feedback
that I would like to to make is
that.
Most people learn this kind of
by trial and error, and that is
when you have the.
Indication based information
versus the worldwide.
Indication sales indication
based sales, I I think there
needs to be a way to clarify
what that does to your report.
OK. Yeah. And what you're
looking at because?
It can get confusing.
He can get confusing. Um,
regarding um.
Yeah, train of thought is not
doing too well today. It can't
get confusing as to what you're
looking at because you have
repeating rows, you know, and
things like that, and that's
regardless of what an interface
that's going to be on. So these
are things that I think there
could be a little pop-ups or
something explaining it or or
something. I I think that there
are some mapping issues. You
know I I I I'm the bug Finder.
I, I find all the little bugs
and all the.
Interfaces all the time. And so
I I a couple of years ago, when
I first started, I was working
with Griffin.
Siegel, yes, he was our account
tech support and we were trying
to create these very complex
reports for this person in tech
in operations and we were having
problems. Some fields just
weren't mapping right and this
would not be that, but.
When people are doing
indications and worldwide sales,
they they need to understand
what they're looking at and I
think that needs to be on.
Somehow.
Alerted to somehow on the
screen. I'm not sure how one
would do that, but I know that
that causes confusion. Same with
the orphan drug status, the
orphan drug.
Uh, not status but um.
But when a country.
Approved orphan drug status.
And you're putting if you just
have a drug versus the
indication, drug indication
pair, the ACID indication pair
because the the orphan status is
by indication not by drug and
that gets people confused as
well. So the, the, the the
orphan status is for that asset
at that indication.
Only so these are things that
could be clarified somehow.
We'll take that back to the
team. Thank you. This is really
useful feedback.
Umm.
Can I just ohh I've got the UM
date field here so just wanted
to show you what the filtering
options are here so you can
filter on a specific date range.
So you can filter from and then
it gives you the the the entire
view from whatever date you
choose you can choose. This
becomes. This becomes
problematic when you put just a
column for patent data without
any context for what patent
we're looking at. What kind of
patent is this? Is this a
formulation? Is this the? The?
You know, is this a loss of
exclusivity patent? What? What
are we looking at? So this can
be dangerous because you can get
wrong or misleading information
without knowing what this
patent, what this patent column
actually means. OK, patent
expiry, but there's multiple
patents per drug.
What are we looking at here?
Right. What the explanation? I
think you know what we have at
the moment. When you click
through the column title, it
gives you the definition. Would
that help? Would that help?
Yeah, it also have yeah, you
cannot get rid of the Cheat
Sheets.
I gotcha. You gotta have the
definitions, yeah, because.
They are very helpful,
especially when you're doing.
Modeling or you're doing
anything else where you need to
understand the scope of the
field the the actual definition
of the field.
Having it.
Easy for him. I'm trying to
remember now.
I haven't gotten into evaluate.
I was going into evaluate a lot
more last few months. I have not
been going into it.
Except in the I've been going
into Omnia more than anything
else. So I I um.
Uh.
The the You know an easy way to
either get to the definitions.
Uh, whether it's a help button
or click on the uh, the, the
heading, whatever works, but
there has to be.
A easy way of looking at the
definition for the field. OK,
that's really helpful.
Um, OK. I think this is
everything that I wanted to show
you today in terms of the new
platform, what do you think
about the report builder, the
the functionality? I'm I'm not
sure.
And I think it's it's basically
good. Uh.
I I want to play with.
Yes, I'll have to play with it
to get a sense of how easy is it
to find the different
attributes, the different
fields.
Umm, I think I like the fact
that you have them maybe grouped
in a better way. The other way
was a little confusing, so I
think there are so many
sections. That was the part that
was a little problematic. Your
eyes would start to cross after
a while. There's so much data in
this database, so if there's a
easier way to corral it into
categories.
I will look for that when I test
it.
Right, because it would be,
yeah, sorry, go on. No, no,
that's. So that would be an
important thing. If that has
made that a little more obvious
or clear where all the fields
are, that would be useful.
OK, perfect. Well, thank you
very much. That would be really
helpful, Judith, if you could go
in yourself and have a have a
walk around, see what you've
been kind of meaning to for a
while, but I never did.
Whenever, whenever you've got
time. We're always, we're
always, uh, we always welcome
feedback, but that's everything
from me. Thank you very much.
I'm Keith. Over to you. Thank
you very much. Judith. I'm
conscious that we're a couple of
minutes over. Are you OK for
time? Yes.
OK, cool. So it won't be long.
Um, I just wanted to ask you a
quick question about
visualizations actually. So on
the index page that you see in
when magma clicked on browse
data and then you've got your
metrics and then you add your
events top three therapeutic
categories. We're also looking
to put some charting and
visualizations on that. It's
just to get.
Initial thoughts on what kind of
charting would be beneficial for
you? Do you? Did you often use
characterization on that page?
Would only be useful if the
dashboard was immediately
filterable by attributes that
are useful to us. So the page as
it stands now would not serve us
serve a lot of purpose to us at
all in any in any form.
Uh, in terms of data, especially
in terms of data visualization,
as I mentioned earlier, I think
we're probably more interested
in the data visualization after
we run the query.
So if these charts could be
filterable or queryable in some
way and then adapted.
Uh.
Changed.
That could be useful.
OK, yeah, I'm just showing an
example here. So this is this is
this is not um yet your website.
This is just a prototype. But
yeah you can see a bar chart
there. And I guess once you've
applied your filters here at the
bottom table your calculated
metrics at the top would adjust
and then so would your
visualization. So would there be
a don't want we don't want to
get to the if you're gonna put a
lot of stuff on the top, we
wanna, we will often want to
create the report.
So OK, we don't want to Scroll
down a lot, so.
That's where I think we're
having a a view.
How to view this?
Module differently.
Other people might want to see
that, but we would want the
option of maybe a little close,
close, close, close, close and
set or setting so we don't see
any of this. Other people may
like it. So if we could have an
option, we don't see all of it
and then we can just immediately
start doing our search or keep a
couple things up there that
would be useful for us if we can
customize it, and that way if we
could customize that so we don't
Scroll down, you know, two
screens before we get to where
we can do our search.
So I think, I think the idea of
being able to those sections
collapse that that was the word
I was looking for. Thank you.
Collapse or uncollapsed those
different.
The different data
visualizations and then set that
as a setting. For us that would
be.
Great, because obviously we're
not your biggest use case, um,
compared to someone, but there
could very well be someone who's
only works in neuro Neurology.
And they're focused on.
Maybe one or two mechanisms of
action. Well, they could
customize their dashboard for
that, and they maybe want to see
all the visualizations, but
that's what we call a sliver and
Long Island, we call that a
sliver.
I am, uh, I'm a sliver of data.
Most of my family lives on data.
Yeah, well, we tend to call them
slices. Yes, yes, yes. There's
maybe it's English slices of
bread sandwiches. I don't know.
Maybe. No, it's it's it's it's
my Long Island Jewish
background. You guys, I'm gonna
cut you a sliver. I'm on a diet.
I'm gonna cut you a sliver.
I have had 10 before as well.
Actually. I think that's what my
aunt is. Aunties and uncles say,
you know, slither of cake. Um,
cool. I am conscious that we
have gone 5 minutes over. That
was the only thing I wanted to
ask. Um, actually that's a like
final question. Do you ever use
our data on the go or do you
ever use anyone else's data on
the go, IE on a remote?
Absolutely probably not because
I don't know what you mean by
data on the go.
OK, apologies. So would you ever
act so data sources just such as
evaluate and whichever other
sort of data providers you use,
would you ever log into their
dashboards and their platforms
on any other device such as a
mobile or a tablet or is it a
laptop or a desktop is
predominantly what you use?
Don't travel much at all. Uh,
we're actually for the past two
years I haven't gone anywhere
much at all except for an annual
vacation. So it's really sad.
But that being beside the point,
I would never want to attempt to
do what I need to do on these
platforms on a phone. And I have
a big phone.
No worries, that's fine. It's a
big phone.
No, if I was the type of person
who maybe was a business
development person who needed to
look up a compound.
Yes. Or a company then maybe,
but trying to do complex market
stuff. Yeah, I I'm not
interested. 4 year old, it's not
that relevant. Yeah. And for my
role it's not relevant. So for
some other people's role it
might be.
Yeah, people. I mean, you know,
I mean, I could see Cornell
wanting to needing to do it, but
not wanting to do it on a phone.
I'll wait till I get back to my
hotel room and I'll open up the
computer. It it's just it's too
it's too much unless you're
doing a simple lookup.
OK. That that's great for you,
but we'll give that back. Cool.
So yeah. No, no more questions
for me, I promise.
Images that we've got a few
minutes. No, that's OK that
there was a light day today in
terms of meetings.
OK, that's good to hear. So what
we'll do after this is, um, like
Magna said, you, you have access
to the new platform. You'll have
an evaluate beta button when you
log in. It'll be a blue one and
just sort of next to the search
bar. So yeah, we would, we would
encourage you to go and play
around yourself. And there is a
feedback survey. Uh, if you go
onto the platform in the bottom
left, you've got like a purple
paper plane icon. If you click
that, there's two options. You
could just give feedback and
just say what you want.
Open-ended text box or.
There's also a specific survey
that you could fill out. Um, so
there's about roughly about 20
questions that take about 5-6
minutes to fill out. But if it's
just right, if it's just little
bits of specific feedback, just
click, give feedback and then
you'll get presented with a box
and an option to like.
Pays any screenshots or anything
like that. So yeah, I'll, I'll
follow up on the e-mail. I'll,
I'll just, um, I'll give you the
details on e-mail as well. So
you've got it in writing and
then if you can do that, that
would be absolutely brilliant.
Um, if not, then your feedback
today and Cornell's feedback has
been absolutely amazing. So
we'll pass that back to the team
and then what we'll also do is,
you know, going through a
process of speaking to numerous
customers, once we've gathered
the feedback, we've identified,
you know, what we're going to
take on board and how we're
going to address that. I'll then
reach out in sort of two or
three weeks.
Just to show you this is what
you said and this is what we're
going to do, just to close that
loop so that sound OK and I can
always tell when I'm speaking,
even if I didn't hear an accent,
I would know you were Brit.
With the brilliant, brilliant,
brilliant.
That is.
Sometimes it's not even the full
word. It's just a Brill. And
sometimes it doesn't. Just five
letters. Yeah, just 5 letters.
My favorite talk show ever
invented is the Graham Norton
Show.
And.
And they just get one.
I only found that in the last
couple years due to COVID and me
spending too much time on my
phone and.
It is far and away the best talk
show.
On the planet. And we've been
doing it for like 25 years or
something, but it's.